chucko prioritize and execute is it
wrong to sacrifice health in short-term
to accomplish work objectives and how
would you make up the time lost so yeah
absolutely sometimes you have to
sacrifice workouts for health and health
for work objectives there's no doubt
that's life and work in many respects is
life and that's kind of another topic
but try and love what you're doing try
and enjoy your job if you don't because
if you enjoy your job then work is life
isn't okay thing if you hate your job
then work is life is not it's not a good
situation to be in
so try and get into things and do
something that you enjoy doing and if
you don't enjoy it you know find some
kind of an exit strategy but that's
another topic going back to this topic
is it okay or is it wrong to sacrifice
your health in the short term to
accomplish long term work objectives and
yeah even in the SEAL Teams we did that
all kinds of times a lot the weather was
in training or for mission where our
priority or a mission or our training
takes priority over workouts and over
eating healthy and over everything so
there's times where that you're just
100% focused on some kind of mission and
that's what you're gonna that's what
you're gonna do and that's okay that's
what we did in the SEAL Teams and that's
what everyone does and it's and when you
get done with that how do you make up
for lost time you do some hard workouts
and maybe you go eat super clean or you
fast for a little while or whatever it
is that gets you back on track you just
get yourself back on track but you have
to watch out for is a pattern a
long-term pattern where work takes
precedent over health for multiple weeks
right multiple weeks in months right if
it's if you're talking about months
we're in a bad situation like if you go
week two weeks where you just were crazy
and working was crazy and you you know
you know your health took a little to
went down a couple notches on the
priority and a couple weeks goes by and
you cook forward I'm glad I've got
through that and the the the hard
seasons over or the whatever then you
know
well you know you people in the finance
world and tax season they're just
busting their ass for two three four
straight weeks it's really hard it's
understandable and you know retail
people around Christmastime they're or
you know that everyone's got their
little cyclical things real estate
people in the springtime and the summer
starts rolling around their work it's
it's there's cyclical things and that's
cool you work hard for two three weeks
where you just have to get after it but
when that starts turning into months in
in multiple weeks and then months and
then radicular months of your health is
taking the backseat we have an issue now
that being said there are not too many
jobs that consume 23 and a half hours a
day of your time they're just not that
many jobs that do that now what in what
you might be facing here you might be
blaming your job for you being lazy mmm
that that can be happening that's a
strong possibility actually because you
can make time for a 20 minute workout
right 20 minute workout right 20 minute
workout like that if you get 20 minutes
you're getting to shake it out a little
bit and you do you know a couple hundred
burpees go as hard as you can you just
got a workout that took you 10 15 20
minutes right well you know longer than
that for me but ya know you see what I'm
saying though I do yes fully you do and
then if you can do that if you sprint if
you do ten Sprint's right doesn't take
you much time you do go go and knock out
three four or five sets of pull-ups go
knock out a couple hundred pull-ups how
long does that take it doesn't take that
long right take you 15 minutes you're
done so then maybe at night you just
roll up there you grab your cattle bone
you knock out some swings it takes you
seven minutes we're not talking about a
bunch of times so are we being lazy cuz
we're not carving out 15-20 minutes half
an hour you know a lot of people ask me
about what the workouts I do when I'm on
the road a lot of times when I'm on the
road I fly into a city I get there 11
o'clock at night the next time next day
I'm working with a company at 8 o'clock
in the morning and so I my schedules
tight I'm
the hotel room the hotel room gym sucks
for for one thing and I'm gonna bang
something out quickly hmm you know it's
not gonna be an hour workout no it's
gonna be like 20 minutes sometimes now
sometimes if I have a little extra time
maybe I'm not meeting with the company
until lunch cool I'm gonna have a nice
long workout of course but if it's I'm
due to meet with the CEO for breakfast
at 7 o'clock it's gonna be a quick
hardcore 12 minute workout
yeah and that's cool so you got to carve
that out and this is so you you know
make sure that it's the job that's doing
this to you and not you that's doing
this to you yeah so if it is your job
truly truly your job is the thing that's
making you unhealthy then you gotta fix
it now what you have going for you is
that companies want you to be healthy
right companies understand the benefit
of having healthy employees not just
from a Productivity standpoint but from
like an insurance viewpoint we if we got
out you know we've got a health coverage
for our employees and all of our
employees are are sick and lame and lazy
and we're having to pay their medical
bills and they can't work it's
problematic so what you do is you step
up and you say hey you know what we
don't have a health and wellness program
I want to run it we need a little gym oh
yeah it's gonna cost money yes it's
gonna cost money but I'm gonna save you
money in productivity I'm gonna save you
money in insurance I'm gonna write a
point paper on that I'm gonna win that
one all day long we're gonna we're gonna
put a gym in the lounge and we're gonna
put we're gonna put some mats in the
doughnut room you know what I'm sayin so
we're gonna help we're gonna do it well
I think LinkedIn has a jiu-jitsu
room you mean like the headquarter I
think I saw a picture of they have a
jiu-jitsu room good idea yeah you
wouldn't have to pay me to work there
you got to do some free members yeah so
you get so go you know step up your
company I can not guarantee your company
wants you to be healthy hmm
so step up maybe take leadership role in
forming the health and wellness program
for your company get it
when may my brother's company you know
it rack mop
yeah they don't have a been on Matson
you know obviously in the office but yet
yet yeah but um it's funny though he'll
like he'll do this he'll encourage
people to go to jiu-jitsu you know yeah
to the point where they have rash guards
even yeah we have a pretty good
representation from fragment about the
gym yeah you know what I call everyone
from frack mom that trains you know and
I'd nicknamed them want all of them
frack mop gym anymore no your name is
Frank mop
yeah so but that's good because it
becomes this culture that kind of
catches on you know where and this is
just jiu-jitsu it can be kind of
anything CrossFit or even spin I don't
know whatever but just is kind of good
because it's one of those ones that you
can kind of come and talk about it and
you know or choked you out or you choke
me out kind of thing you can choke your
boss if he's that you know it's like
that kind of so it's real Schwann your
boss and they even have like rat like I
said rash guards the rash guards like if
you work for a fragment it'll say um
staff on the back it'll have like you
know you know they do like AI and yeah
you know development stuff like that so
the the staff one will be um what does
it have on the sleeves like digital
digital circuitry yeah and then the
other one says will say security that's
like you know friends of the friends or
the forces between the hardware and the
software rash guard so the soffit guys
who actually work for fragment have the
software a rash guards that as like
circuitry on the design and then the
know the hardware oh sorry the software
is that little zeros and ones yes the
code in the security guys who were
anyway nonetheless that's kind of that's
like a good look cuz that's not really
an official program in fragment or see
in a company it's just it's kind of the
influential element of the culture you
know where it's like and you know my
brother he he he pushed that you know
not kind of overtly I guess but it's
more it was like you guys have to do
this it's kind of like hey you should
come down I'll give you a rash garden
okay cool and guys and it was funny
there's a time there's a bunch of
fragment in there just going didn't you
think but yeah that helps that it does
not for sure now the thing is if none of
that works if you give you calm
he's just dragging you down and and
you've checked and double-checked and
triple-checked your own discipline or
lack of discipline mm-hmm and you
realize that it's the work that is
bringing down your health in that case
you got to follow the procedure you got
to find an exit strategy create an exit
strategy save up your money line things
up get the ducks and roe and then
execute because your health is gonna be
more important than everything else yeah
then everything else all that money you
could possibly make if you got to
sacrifice a year and a half two years
and you've got to grind it out like an
investment banker that shows up on Wall
Street who's gonna grind for two years
and their health is gonna suffer but
they've got a goal at the end of that a
understood you sometimes you got to do
but you gotta at the end that two three
years you know you're not there and
you're not where you want to be and
you're starting to decline in health
they're gonna get some stuff that you
won't be able to recover from so make
your make your decision then you come up
with an exit strategy and move on do
something else
yeah and health health and even like
fitness is is this thing it's called
systemic versus direct you know as far
as being beneficial so exercise is like
one of the few things in your little
hierarchy of like needs or whatever that
affects everything else like if you if
you're an unhealthy person versus a
healthy person the healthy person will
be better at everything else he'll be
better at making money he'll be better
at them all relationships he'll be
better
obviously health-wise in and of yourself
I mean obviously if you've got some guy
that's brilliant and really out of shape
versus a guy that's an idiot who's in
great shape the brilliant person is
probably gonna make more money and do
better in the long run of me and we're
talking you have to put them on a level
intellectual playing yeah you're talking
about the same person oh yeah then for
sure for sure but healthier person was
gonna win but it so can compare that to
the direct thing like will people be
like a making money's important so it's
more important than health but here's
think making money doesn't improve your
health
making money doesn't necessarily improve
friendship or romantic relationships
necessarily in fact a lot of times it
damages them a lot of the times health
doesn't damage any
it improves everything there's not
anything that I can think of anyway that
health makes worse
yeah or being more fit makes worse get
healthy stay healthy yeah stay on the
program you know what um
and it's one of those things to men
those like working out when you're on
the road that's a big one right it's
hard to like get a solid workout on the
road because you're busy or whatever but
there's this is gonna sound crazy when
you think about it's not not crazy but
some kind of unrealistic where okay so
this is what I've been doing recently
one of them when we went to New York for
the muster and like all these are
something before I go I'll research
jiu-jitsu gyms and fitness gyms where I
can work out because like you said the
hotel gym is like if you don't have
anything else in here but you still have
time okay good but I research where are
the gyms and prepare like okay how long
is it gonna take me to get there work
out get back all this stuff and then you
fit it in your schedule and here's the
thing if you don't wanna fit in your
schedule then don't work out then you've
been health is not for you then but if
you're like oh your ass is you know this
kind of question where you know is it
wrong to sacrifice health and all this
stuff that means you're concerned about
health then be concerned about health
you can fit it in surprised what you can
fit in just like you don't have to get
that good of a workout but you're
fitting it in but here's the thing you
can fit in a good workout you just gotta
make yeah for that you gotta plan it's a
psychological win to like I if I'm gonna
speak somewhere he add a minimum I'll do
a couple hundred burpees before when I
wake up yes that just gets the blood
flowing you're ready to rock and roll
yeah but at the muster I there was no
break in the program I went to 24-hour
fitness that I've rolled a hard one and
hanzo's and then we rolled that at the
muster which wasn't hard necessarily but
there's a lot of rolls in there and so
man it was there was no break in the
program but the point is because I knew
that that was I made time exactly right
it was important and I don't say it's
important like it's the number one
priority I'm saying it's part of the the
whole what I'm doing it's not part of
what you're doing then don't be healthy
then don't make it part of what you're
doing I vote against you on that one
I say make time be healthy yeah I think
so too that's my opinion but I'm saying
help no I know exactly like you're
saying
my job is so whatever if you straight-up
don't have time then you don't have time
health is not for you you chose
everything else we're helping and that's
up to you
I'm gonna go ahead going on a limb here
that most people you can make time
that's the point
that's my Waco a half hour earlier yeah
cuz you know you know when you really
don't have time yeah yeah yeah like one
time Viner of two or three months ago we
were we came in and we skipped jiu-jitsu
to record the podcast right and I was
like man we skip jiu-jitsu to record the
primaries good we had no choice but it
was like we didn't do that we weren't
about the guy to flight in the afternoon
and we just had to do it yes and so yeah
occasionally that those things happen
yes so consider that all right so it's
either skip jujitsu one day and get the
podcasts out or don't we could ease we
could have chosen trained jiu-jitsu
don't do the podcast but at that point
given all the circumstances the podcast
that one day it's keeping Giselle one
day is more important for that one day
because it's not like we're giving up
jiu-jitsu completely for this but it's
not not actually holding the line with
the podcast exactly right and that was
important that day because we're kind of
faced with that thing what do you give
up so what that's the question what do
you give up
do you give up watching a you know a
movie and room service do you give that
up give that give that up
like I said hey you don't have yes we
don't I go to hotels I don't even turn
on the TV yeah Ben I don't pretend to
you because I don't have TV at home and
so I don't know a year or two ago I I
went to some hotel and I turned on the
TV and next thing I know you know an
hour and a half went by and I was
watching some movie from 1986 zulan
going you've got to be kidding me
turn it off you know what I always do I
hang my chalk bag on the TV that's my
standard operator I hang my job because
you know they're all the thin TVs well
when you travel when I travel so you
bring your chocolate yes I brought back
I bring sweatbands for my rest cause I
sweat I bring a choc back I bring my
little notebook time grains gum a
mobility wad ball to do some mobility
work and I bring some one inch tubular
nylon that I used to stretch bring your
good delusionally like when we went to
the monster I brought
with me yes so that good cuz I knew I
was gonna be on a tight timeline anu is
gonna have to you know get some workouts
done and I travelled a little bit
heavier yeah cuz I normally travel
really light but I had an extra bag so
then no rings a mint no factor you were
there for a while - yeah a couple weeks
yeah I was in Austria and then came back
to New York and then from New York to
Texas so there's a road trip yeah
dang see and you made it happen and
you're busier than the normal person
in my opinion kind of busy in from yeah
but again man I I think you know how
that old saying I think I don't know you
might have said might have been the
Henry I don't know where I saw it but
it's like there is no free time or spare
time or you know work that there's just
time you know it's it's one of those who
do lifetime that is Rollins that's a run
yeah yeah so it's like time so there's
no spare time there's no free time
there's just like just the time yes you
better just get on it so unless you're
like Peter at II remember when he was
talking about what Peter Thiel was
talking about like there is no time
you're just working the whole time like
you can't even use it med school yeah
yeah yeah so if you're in that situation
then that may be like hey I'm not doing
this part of the program you pull down
the side of the road to a park to fall
asleep hour because yeah it's not the
nine days yeah so there are exceptions
for sure but again like if you're into
doing room service or you're you know
you're watching the game or you stopping
at the bar or doing anything I'm not
even saying necessarily destructive
things I'm just saying things that don't
aren't conducive to your quote unquote
work that's keeping you so busy or
whatever that are essential if you're
doing these other things then there's
where you can make time how can one ever
have time if you don't take time I like
it